this is a production of Cornell
University
okay so then after impeding hold you
have types of the PhD I'm also going to
compare to beagle as a common imputation
software to see how it how it holds up
and compares so first I started with
over 180 taxa from the hapmap to in
cassava
these are these come from this PC Aegis
is from a paper a couple years ago by
remove Pune at all and it's just showing
that there's a definitely a lot of
progenitors and cultivated types in here
but there's also some more diverse in
wild in this hapmap as well I'm
restarting with the cultivated adding on
just to see how that compares and these
reference ranges or haplotypes are
defined I'm using just the genic ranges
plus a flanking kb on either side around
33,000 across the genome so then comes
back to my question of how do we find
haplotypes and something like sorghum a
maze that's inbred it might be it's a
little easier because you don't have to
worry about sampling heterozygous
variants but in our case with cassava
which is highly heterozygous or inbred
crop or sorry it's a cloning property
crop one can imagine three variants
across a region a see I guess CC is a
homozygous variant we're okay there but
and then a GT variant we could choose
two haplotypes here a c g and c CT but
that's you know that's one option the
other option would be what we call
another phase which is a CT and c cg
this problem just gets harder and harder
as you had more variance there's you
know a lot of lot of possibilities many
many so how do we resolve the true phase
how do we because we need haplotypes in
the database before we can do any
imputation so one way to look is if we
can sample taxa that are homozygous at a
range we even know the true phase right
there i mean i already said they're not
homozygous or heterozygous but if we do
find some homozygotes we can know what
the true haplotype phase is and so
because these are many are cultivated or
you know come from breeding programs
we expect there to be runs upon a
zygosity from years of selection and and
breeding efforts so I went to go test
that hypothesis and this is why I found
so this is just a distribution of kind
of number of heterozygous snips per
genic range and you can see I mean
there's a kind of this spike and then
this hump off the side but when I focus
on the spike here's those haplotypes
with near zero heterozygous snips
so it actually goes off the top
it's just cut off but that makes those
make up around twenty percent of all of
the haplotypes from these taxa and if
you take that twenty percent times by
the 180 all of them you know over a
million raw haplotypes that can then be
put into the database just once again
not going too far into but to simplify
the search space we will collapse of
these haplotypes based on similarity so
if some of them are you know only vary
by a snip or two or some small amounts
of variation they'll be collapsed to a
consensus outside so next I'm going to
test some levels of imputation accuracy
so mainly how well do they do a major
heterozygous and minor alleles and I
also looked at maybe expanding the
database to something just out a bit
cultivated set so the smallest red
circle would just be just the cultivated
and then I added the rest of the hapmap
and then even some more additional
clones we have sequenced and what I see
here is that the smallest that abase
actually did pretty well at the
heterozygotes but overall as we add as
we sample more haplotypes and get those
into the database the imputation that
you see is increasing in overall so next
not only do I want you know good variant
call accuracy
I'd also like to reproduce relationships
because when we do zoom selection we
need to make sure that you know we're
that we're predicting true relationships
and so what I did next was compared
compared the whole genome high depth
relation
matrices made from whole genome sequence
to the ones predicted by both beagle and
the PhD so this is using 1x skim
sequencing and imputing with these two
methods and I found that the PhD had a
much higher I mean as it has a higher
correlation for sure in in these
relationships that it's reproducing next
step which I have not performed yet will
be validating this looking at phenotypes
in a in a test set and comparing those
but for now the in conclusion there are
there are enough homozygous homozygous
regions across the hapmap that we can
sample haplotypes to store our data base
and impute whole genome high-quality
relationships from them next like I said
I'll be used need to be looking for a
good test set to test you know
predictions also maybe adding additional
parameters to the model that might be
all include maybe pedigree or
relationships for where does so we're to
empower types from and then as well as
maybe simulating real you know real ich
genotyping situations in their breeding
program might use and with that I'd like
to thank you and acknowledge all of
those that have helped especially the
programmers that work on the PhD the
other grad students have helped my
advisers Kelly and Edie and gimmick sama
base for data help and I'll take any
questions
[Applause]
time for a few questions yeah just easy
one I hope maybe graph showing predicted
versus true where do you get really yeah
so that's I I just used the 30 X like
high depth high depth sequencing that I
pulled from so as it makes it so I down
sampled from high depth sequencing I
just made a relationship matrix from
those and then I'm just comparing how
the imputed compare the correlation
between those relationships and the ones
empty install on that on the 180 yes yes
none of the yeah none of the wilds I got
and I introduced I may have built upon
the database but I'm only working on
some of those cultivated 180s yeah my I
I've not done that right now I've been
using just kind of one chromosome as a
so I can iterate quickly and test
quickly I do know that there are some
presence/absence variation I'm when I
look across the haplotypes there are
some texts that have almost no coverage
you know on a few
how about that ranges so there's
definitely some maybe some
presence/absence issues but I have not
looked at the introgression
I know that's a big deal with chromosome
one which I have not is why I've been
avoiding from someone so I haven't
looked a spatial distribution I have
looked at like the distribution how many
some there are some haplotypes that are
definitely less sampled than others
because they're less let's say you know
let's say if there's a lot of
variance or something that needs to be
masked it's not going to be homozygous
very often and so there are some
haplotypes I've found that that I can't
sample as deep from because there's not
as many homozygous but I haven't looked
at that spatially distributes across the
chromosome our apologies to the people
on Zoom do you have any questions
doesn't seem like it okay all right well
thanks again Evan this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu